here's a video of mazvidal uh street
fighting back in the days
uh yeah miami so but put the audio so we
can hear it in jorts look at the jorts
nobody rocks shorts and his belt is not
even at the right loop
can you move that one okay there you go
that's great technique though man he has
you see how his hands are right so he's
catching everything so the guy even if
he does land he's getting kind of
deflected off of his hands he's not
blinking either i mean he can't teach
that no
this guy's way bigger way bigger but
he's doing it
doing a good thing going to the body now
he's gonna go over top
how old is he here i'm curious 20.
[Music]
the composure though that's that's what
i'm looking at see how composed
[Applause]
still going to the body like a kimbo
slice in the background bro
oh oh oh oh the spinning backhand
but you know what it is though like this
guy is getting off on him too but it's
the posturing that
george is doing afterwards to let the
guy know that he hasn't landed anything
so the guy's losing confidence wow
so that plays as big of a role
you imagine the guy next door at the
taco joint just waiting 20 minutes like
wow
like i just wanted this in miami by the
way i do this every week yeah i don't
know if you guys really think i'm at
oh
see oh
what what is the what is the laws
against street fights like i knew you
had none of this is legal
no no you were doing the underground you
know the fight club type of thing
all of this is illegal right you can't
this is illegal
a fight is illegal but a street fight
paying betting that's that's the part
that's illegal that's illegal yeah
this is a throwback man to when they
used to have fights on the barges
outside of uh new york city because
fighting was illegal in the turn of the
century so they'd get on the barges
float out and then they'd have these
these massive fights
see now now that jorge got his time and
now he knows he got his time and it's
over at this point yeah well this is
also why there's rounds right i mean oh
that knee got him
that's what you're saying a heavyweight
just has to get around once right that's
it
it's the posture it's the posture that
he has and he's not
bro and you think kobe is going to take
down mastodon
i mean i love myself man he's my guy but
i just think that kobe
he has a wrestling he has a wrestling
that wrestling mm-hmm is just is at
another level because he doesn't stop
the pace that he's able to wrestle not a
lot of people can handle that pace you
know it's all about pace you know and if
you're a guy like colby covington who
can keep pushing the pace and go and go
and go it's hard to defeat a guy like
that you know and and mozart all you
know they trained together before so
there there's a lot more to it you know
what i'm saying and there's there's more
to the story you know what i'm saying
kobe didn't call this guy out he didn't
call jorge out because he didn't think
that he could beat him there's something
that happened in the training that he
remembers that mazda remembers that is
going to play a lot of animosity there
though oh yeah this one this one is real
animosity and it's been for a few years
of animosity it's not like it's a new
thing yeah it's it's been brewing for a
while man you know it's but you know
it's hard to to go against uh mazda you
know what i'm saying because mazda you
know he came out on the scene and he he
uh really showed who he was within the
last couple years and it seems like a
lot of things have come together for him
but i mean kobe covington is yeah and
usman beat both of them though yeah who
does he think is going to win
that's your guy i don't know i i would
say if i was a guest for him i'll say
he'll think that kobe cummings is going
to do that because
he's like the only guy that's giving his
men even a little bit of problem i mean
the last few fights
yeah i mean if it goes if it goes the
sixth round and that last covington was
coming on i couldn't believe it i
thought he was done we went to europe of
course the second round we were like
there's something very unique about kobe
by the way there's there's a dog fight
in him yeah you know there's a very
unique thing about him about mazda
here's the thing about masuda you saw
how that guy just not punched uh maz
vidal all of a sudden and maswara was
dropped
that could happen with jorge jorge has a
weapon and if one of these things
connect kobe's got a great uh you know
he can he can take it yeah but mazvidal
can give it it'll be interesting what
happens i think vegas is way towards
kobe than mazda is uh is usman looking
at gaichi next or is he looking to move
up in weight class
um
i think i think they might be trying to
fight uh
was it who was it like uh who's it uh
edwards or something like that oh
edwards yeah not gateshea really but
they're they're training partners oh so
they this is the whole like leota
machido and uh anderson
well geichi's at 155
he's coming up though isn't he no
after the chandler fight he's staying
down there you can say it on there yeah
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]